تستعد الى طائرات وطلائع الجسر الجوي
السعودي اللغاتي لمساعده الشعب السوداني
بالاقلاع عبر عديد من المساعدات التي سيتم
ارسالها عبر هذه الطائره العسكريه التي
ستحمل بعشره اطنان موزعه على عدد من
المساعدات الهوائيه والغذائيه والدوائيه
وتحمل على متنها ايضا فريق من مركز الملك
سلمان بالاضافه الى فريق حمايه سيذهب
مباشره الى مطار بورتسودان لانزال هذه
المساعدات مباشره كما انه سيكون هنالك
طائره اخرى ستقلع بعد ساعات من مطار
الرياض الى بورت السودان لانزال المساعدات
مباشره الى المطار السوداني سنتحدث اكثر
مع الدكتور سامر الجطيلي متحدث الرسمي
باسم مركز الملك سلمان للغاته والاعمال
الانسانيه دكتور حدثنا عن اولى طلائع هذا
الجسر وما تحميله من مساعدات
حياكم الله تنطلق اول طائره يتم تحويلها
تحميلها حاليا وهي اول طائره من الجسر
الجوي انفاذا لتوجيهات سيدي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين واولي عهدي الامين
بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه والاغاثيه
للشعب السوداني الشقيق هذه الطائرات تحمل
حوالي عشر اطنان من المواد الغذائيه
والمواد الايوائيه وكذلك المواد الطبيه
والتي تمثل الحقيقه اهم الاحتياجات في هذه
المرحله سوف تتبع هذه الطائره طائره اخرى
اليوم وسوف يستمر هذا الجسر الجوي باذن
الله عز وجل حتى نصل الى مستهدفنا وحتى
نحقق توجيه السامي الكريم بايصال
المساعدات للاشقه في السودان هذا اول
الخير نسال الله عز وجل التوفيق ونسال
الله عز وجل ان نكون على قدر هذه المهمه
الكبيره التي اوليت لنا في مركز الملك
سلمان الشكر الجزيل لوزاره الدفاع للقوات
الملكيه السعوديه والتي الحقيقه تقوم الان
مشكوره
بهذا الجسر الجوي نسعى باذن الله عز وجل
لتحقيق اثر وصناعه الحقيق تغيير في حياه
المحتاجين في هذه المرحله من الازمه
والصراع في السودان شكرا جزيلا الدكتور
اذا انت استعد هذه الطائره الى الاقلاع
بعد قليل وهي هذه الطائره ستحمل هذه
المساعده الواقعه بين بورتسودان الى
الخرطوم على ان تستمر هذه العمليه خلال
الايام القادمه وسط حمله شعبيه نودي لها
هنا بالسعوديه للتبرع على ان تستمر هذه
الى ايام واسابيع قادمه وان تصل الى كافه
الولايات السودانيه
التي تحتاج هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل عبد
المحسن الحربي لقناتي العربيه والحدث
الرياض لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات